das hört sich echt an wie aus einem
schauerroman lebendige roboter sie
können sich fortbewegen kleine lasten
transportieren und sich selbst heilen
bei den sogenannten zeno bots handelt es
sich nach angaben eines us
forschungsteams tatsächlich um lebendige
programmierbare organismen entworfen
wurden die winzigen roboter die aus
frosch zellen bestehen von einem
supercomputer ist das also wirklich die
erste lebende maschine der weltkriegs
uns ein wirklich spannendes seines
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen das ist
wirklich vollkommen die zähne bots
lassen science fiction war werden und
vielleicht auch horrorfilme ein us
forschungsteam hat nach eigenen angaben
aus vor stammzellen lebendige maschinen
erschaffen und diese roboter könnten uns
in der zukunft sendet sich sein
diese bio roboter sollen nicht nur
medikamente innerhalb des menschlichen
körpers transportieren und verkalkte
arterien vielleicht wieder freilegen
können sondern auch das plastik müll
problem in den meeren bekämpfen die
fachleute von den us universitäten tufts
und vermont haben lange zeit komplexe
simulationen studiert um das
bestmögliche design dieser bio roboter
zu errechnen ein algorithmus wurde
eingesetzt um zu analysieren welche
biologischen bausteine sich für den bau
der kleinen maschinen eignen könnten das
erklärte ziel
die maschinen sollen sich bewegen können
und dabei auch kleine lasten
beziehungsweise gepäckstücken
transportieren können die konstruktion
der winzigen xeno bots erfolgte also
gemäß dem im vorfeld berechneten bauplan
heißt also im klartext die evolution
wurde durch einen super computer
simuliert errechnete auf basis
biophysikalische informationen aus was
einzelne frosch zählen können und wie
diese am besten zusammen zu stellen sind
das forschungsteam ließ den algorithmus
100 mal laufen und der supercomputer
wählte die besten modelle aus diese
konnten dann im labor aus echten zählen
nachgebaut werden fertig war der bio
roboter das ist echt strange dann ging
es mit den herz und haut stammzellen der
afrikanischen frau spezies xenopus
laevis weiter daher übrigens auch der
name xeno bots semmel und wurden die
benötigten stammzellen isoliert und
vermehrt nachdem sie gewachsen waren
wurden sie mit einem mikro
sette und einer elektrode zu einem
gewebe zusammengefügt und zwar strikt
nach den bauplänen die der supercomputer
im vorfeld ausgewählt hatte als gerüst
für die bio roboter dienten die
hautzellen die herzzellen sorgten dafür
dass sich die mini roboter fortbewegen
können die embryonalen energiespeicher
in den zellen liefern die energie dafür
gebraucht wird laut der expertin
experten könnten diese energiereserven
die zellen tage oder sogar wochen lang
mit energie versorgen dazu der münchner
biophysiker friedrich sinne der selbst
nicht an der studie beteiligt war
in einem interview mit dem tagesspiegel
die stammzellen sind mechanisch statisch
aber sie haben das potenzial eine art
gewebe zu bauen
herzmuskelzellen dagegen können
pulsieren und haben daher eine bewegungs
komponente und tatsächlich das
experiment gelang und fertig war der
szene bot mit einer größe von nicht mehr
als einem halben millimeter und diese
fingen dann tatsächlich an sich zu
bewegen
treten die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler die mini roboter aber um
verhältnis sich so wie käfer die hilflos
auf dem rücken liegen
das autorenteam schreibt dazu das legt
nahe dass die bewegungen nicht zufällig
zustande kam sondern durch die ihnen
gegebene formen doch das us
forschungsteam ging noch weiter
sie schufen auch snowboards die sich
nicht nur geradeaus bewegen sondern auch
exemplare die sich kreisförmig bewegen
zudem konnten auch mini roboter gebaut
werden die kleine partikel einsammeln
einzelne exemplare mit einem loch in der
mitte können solche objekte dann sogar
transportieren bislang legt zumindest
eine simulation nahe dass das
funktionieren könnte und somit der hilfe
der mini maschinen beispielsweise
medikamente durch den menschlichen
körper geschleust werden können sogar
für die fachleute selbst gab es eine
überraschung denn die experimente legen
nahe dass zwischen den herzmuskelzellen
eine art kommunikation stattfindet und
so die gerichtete bewegung ermöglicht
wird darum was handelt es sich jetzt bei
diesen bio robotern um tiere oder
maschinen dazu schreibt das autorenteam
sie sind weder ein traditioneller
roboter noch eine bekannten tierart
stattdessen handelt es sich um einen
programmierbaren und lebendigen
organismus neue kategorien seien
notwendig um eine konkrete einordnung zu
ermöglichen das forschungsteam sie
viele vorteile sie seit dieser szene bot
demnach seien diese biologische zellen
für den menschlichen organismus viel
besser verträglich als materialien wie
plastik und metall
zudem kann er einfach ab sterben wenn er
nicht mehr benötigt wird und dann
ähnlich wie eine tote hautzellen sehr
einfach vom körper abgebaut werden ein
weiteres talent der mini roboter sie
können sich selbst heilen
bei den ersten experimenten offenbarte
sich dass die zellen wieder zusammen
wuchs selbst wenn die roboter mit einem
messer fast komplett verteilt worden
waren
das ist eine eigenschaft die
konventionelle maschinen natürlich nicht
bieten können dennoch stellte sich auch
heraus dass die cdu bot schnell
zerfallen und sie sensibel auf
verschiedene einflüsse reagieren
allerdings planen die fachleute auch
noch andere anwendungsmöglichkeiten als
die vielfältigen einsatzgebiete im
menschlichen körper
die bio roboter könnten beispielsweise
auch bestimmte orte nach radioaktiver
kontamination vergiftung ab suchen oder
aber die meere von mikro plastik mit für
einen anderen forscherinnen und forscher
weltweit zeigen sich beeindruckt von
dieser neuen studie doch es gibt zweifel
daran ob sich tatsächlich ja ob es sich
um einen lebenden roboter handelt dazu
sagt friedrich simmel aus münchen
sie bestehen aus zellen und bewegen sich
aber das ist eine sehr weit gefasste
definition dennoch ist klar dass sich
die szene bot prima nutzen lassen um an
weitere spannende erkenntnisse zu
gelangen da ist sich die fachwelt einig
vor allem grundlegende biologische
fragen können damit vielleicht endlich
gelöst werden warum kooperieren zählen
und auf welche art und weise wie
organisieren sie sich speichern und
informationen und wie verarbeiten sie
diese wie gefährlich sind roboter
anklicken anschauen und doktor watson
abonnieren hammer kanal bis dann bleibt
dran